the oregon health authority whose emails
i receive
asked for people who are vaccinated but
not boosted to fill out a questionnaire
i did not because i did not qualify um
but i did go and see what the options
were it's a one question questionnaire
um and it reads oregon health authority
vaccinated but not boosted help us
understand
about 75 of people age 18 and older
across oregon have completed their first
series of vaccinations and only 45 have
also received a booster dose we're
hoping to understand some of the reasons
why people have thus far not received a
booster
if you've been fully vaccinated but have
not had a booster shot please select the
one reason that most closely represents
your situation all responses will remain
anonymous situation they said that about
anonymity several times on the page and
there was no
obvious way for them to have collected
any information about you
so it was a it was
strange and suggested something about
them being able to collect something
from the computer you were logging in to
i i just i'm not sure why they kept
saying that all responses were made
anonymous given that they never
collected anything any identifying
features of you
okay their options that they offer are i
am young and healthy and don't believe i
need it
i would like to get a booster shop but
just haven't gotten around to it
i would like to get a booster shop but i
haven't been able to make the time or
don't have easy access to provider or
clinic
i got co-ed anyway and don't believe the
vaccine works well enough
i had side effects from the vaccine and
don't want to go through that again
people around me are getting coveted 19
and they seem okay so why bother
i want to wait until there is a newer
vaccine that targets the ba.2 omicron
sub-variant
that's a lot of reasonable reasons in
that list
i'm this this list surprises me um
i think many people will not have just
one
one thing on here but this is a match
you know if if the oregon health
authority is concerned because 75
of oregonians are what they consider
fully vac well two dose or one dose of
jnj vaccinated but not boosted and only
45 percent
are boosted
that's a big gap
that's a big loss
um in
for the messaging for the success of the
messaging
and i said sometime back in the fall
this hopefully is where the narrative
crumbles because if they mandate
boosters they're they're going to reveal
how many people will not get boosted
um what we were hearing were a lot of
these things we were hearing from people
i had an adverse event i'm not going
there again i did it it wasn't one and
done like i was told i'm not going there
again or yeah i still got covered what
the hell or actually where's the new one
right like where's the one from for
omicron that we were promised apparently
in march and that um no one is really
talking about it anymore if it you know
it was so quick
to to figure out how to make these in
the first place and it didn't actually
take from you know
march to november of 2020 it was it
actually took kind of a weekend and then
it took a lot of
production
production and trials which were
faulty in their own way um but they're
just
this is a list that reflects
more of the reality of what is actually
going on on the ground with people who
are experiencing covet and vaccines than
anything else i have seen from any
public health messaging yeah i think you
know
somebody is trying to figure out
who to target with what message in order
to get them to change their mind of
course it's not a pure they don't have a
pure goal
my point would be so it accidentally
reveals
the truth of this which is that over
time people woke up to many of the
concerns now there were things that
weren't on there that should have been
unless i misheard it right in other
words um the evidence suggests that
these
vaccines are more dangerous than they
were represented to be
um yeah that's not that's that's that's
a theoretical objection right whereas
the only thing they have on here is i
had side effects from vaccine i don't
want to go through that again right so i
mean well they do have i got covered in
any way and don't believe the vaccine
works well enough which is also a
conflation inflation yeah they do rescue
their little study here with other
yes yeah i didn't
know but it has to be there because it's
hardly a complete solution set so you
need a garbage category somewhere to
catch all those other explanations but
um
but anyway i do think
it reveals that yes people were reached
by messages that were demonized but
nonetheless they heard them and people
had experiences with themselves or other
people having reactions and and that
resulted in uh
more awaken
more people awakened than they would
have hoped for
[Music]
you